but let's jump into the first uh story
now we did cover this story before but
we didn't have
an opportunity to actually sit down with
justin the uh
are you the founder of phoenix yeah so
there are basically three owners of the
company
uh myself my brother kyle
he's the vice president production
manager he runs the shop uh
takes care of all the the real work and
then
our father uh norm nazarov he's also a
an owner as well kind of more of a
passive role but uh
right on so this story is actually just
from i think about a week ago now
reason has it this gun gun shop says it
won't do business with biden voters now
i guess you guys aren't a gun shop
you're an ammunition company
right so the article says tech companies
should have the same freedom to choose
their customers
now this article in particular is is
part is it's funny
it's trying to poke fun at conservatives
complaining about
big tech and censorship and regulation
while pointing out that people are
laughing about the fact that phoenix
ammunition has banned biden voters
when you go to phoenixmbo.com the first
thing you'll see and you can try it
don't leave the podcast just open a new
tab and try it because it actually asks
you a big thing pops up and it says did
you vote for joe biden
yep so okay tell me what's going on
why'd you do it
so it it actually started as a bit of a
of a joke so back when
back when the ammunition market started
to get real crazy
that was at the beginning of the
pandemic people were
kind of panicking and ordering as much
as they could we
we put a check box at
in our checkout page that says in we
just want to let you know it might be
two to four weeks uh before you receive
your order just wanted to make sure that
our customers knew what was going on so
fast forward to post-election i i saw an
article that there was a gun
store in missouri i believe that was
saying that they weren't going to
service joe biden voters and i thought
it was funny and
i like to do some trolling i mean we
have
we you know we we enjoy spicy memes and
you know we've we've
gotten a lot of play out of the epstein
meme
so to speak we have it on our on our
packing slips and so
i said well i'm gonna add an additional
term and condition to the check box that
says
i agree i didn't vote for joe biden just
to see if anybody notices and i'm sure
some of our customers will see it and
laugh
so it was it's been up there since the
beginning of january and
really nobody noticed we had a couple of
of customers who saw it and
and commented on it and laughed so we
did a big sale two weeks ago
and uh i had a woman woman called and
she said
i'm i'm on your website and i want to
order this
ammunition but i'm confused it's asking
me
to check this box that says i didn't
vote for joe biden
and i said well what what can i help you
with and she said
well i did vote for joe biden and i said
well you know to be honest with you we'd
rather not take your money
and she just kind of said what
how are you serious i said yeah did you
know that joe biden wants to ban the
online sale of ammunition and have you
have you actually read any of joe
biden's gun control plan
and she said oh yeah i mean i've read it
but
uh you really aren't going to take my
money i said no i
i don't need it i appreciate the call
but
and so she hung up and she actually
called back about a half an hour later
and we ended up having
about a 45-minute discussion over the
the plan and the politics and she didn't
change her mind
she definitely wasn't going to change my
mind it was a decent back and forth
we had a good time i think and so after
that i thought to myself well
this is actually an opportunity to
educate people
more so than it is just laughing in
their face so
then i added the page that asks
basically a gateway on the website so if
you click
no you're allowed to proceed into the
site it pops up saying yeah exactly so
for joe biden if you go to
phoenixamo.com it will say did you vote
for joe biden if you click no it will
allow you to proceed
if you click yes the site redirects you
to
joebiden.com forward slash gun safety
which is his gun control
platform that he ran on uh it's been up
there for the entirety of his campaign
it's still up there
it was discussed in multiple democratic
debates and
we i can't i personally can't understand
how anybody
could have voted for him and not
understood that that's what he wanted to
do but we wanted to make sure that
if there are gun owners who voted for
joe biden
not knowing what his plans are then this
isn't
this is a good opera we've probably
redirected more people to his site
than he has through his own advertising
well because when he was on
debates he's like text joe biden at
three
three three oh and everyone's like wait
what
it actually says on his website and i've
known i've known this
and the online sale of firearms and
ammunitions right
biden will enact legislation to prohibit
all online sales of firearms ammunition
kits and gun parts
that's gunbroker.com correct that's
that's what what's uh what is it arms
list
arms list uh buds guns arcade gun
i mean most of to be honest with you
it's such a silly thing to say because
especially with firearms let me just
state this for the record
it's been said a million times you
cannot buy a firearm on the internet and
have it shipped
to your home that is not how this works
it's shipped to a gun store
and you go through the exact same
process to be honest it's like ordering
uh if you were to buy a car and have it
sent to a dealership i mean you still
have to fill out the paperwork
do people not no way around that do
people not know that you get background
checked
every time you buy a weapon unless you
have a concealed carry
right so it's nics in some states
a concealed carry permit will exempt you
from getting a background check on every
sale
because you've already been federally
background checked and fingerprinted as
part of the concealed pistol license
process that's how it used to be in
michigan that actually changed
a few months ago but yeah every
every firearm that is sold uh
on the internet so to speak a background
check is conducted
in every one of those instances i think
the exemption
for uh certain i think there's like
certain historical guns you can get
shipped directly to
you like if you want to get like an old
1800s musket yeah
allowed to i don't think anyone's
worried about you getting like you know
an old
what is it called muzzle loader muzzle
loaded yeah i don't think they're super
worried about that
but uh if you want to get uh a 410 so i
recently i tweeted about this i normally
wouldn't tell people what i was mine but
i bought a break barrel three-inch 410
shotgun it's like for snakes and
critters why i shouldn't say critters
because critters technically means
domesticated animals
but uh varmints and it's like you can't
get it or ship to it has to go to a
licensed gun store
you go in and i'm filling out the
paperwork and then you got to wait
and they don't like me they don't they
don't like me when i buy weapons for
some reason so
you know i think i think they're trying
to they slowly start figuring out
because you know i go to the store i
felt the paperwork
but i was getting i was getting delayed
quite a bit but even even for something
like that
you know which is just it holds one
shell at a time it is far from anything
semi-automatic or whatever or even bolt
action and it's gonna
you know fire little pellets for for
getting snakes and and you know badgers
or whatever away from you
and you've got to go through arduous
process for that right these people
i guess they genuinely believe when
biden says this you go online and you're
like i would like one fully automatic 50
bmgs
you know and then sent to right to my
house with a thousand rounds and people
just walk around with these
these not instant weapons yeah nancy
pelosi gets her crew served automatics
sent right to her house i'll be honest i
thought that they sent it right to your
house until just now i
i never learned that information for
whatever reason sure
that's crazy yeah i mean part of that is
just if you haven't really
gone through the process before i mean
it's understandable that in today's age
where
you buy everything on the internet and
it gets shipped right to your house you
know you order something from amazon and
it shows up tomorrow
it's reasonable for somebody who isn't
part of that world to think that that
might be the case
but it's been discussed so many times i
mean this is
it's been this way forever and so it's
it's hard being in the industry
myself it's it's hard to understand why
uh that that trope is still that myth is
still out there
but it's just one that can't die
unfortunately to go back specifically to
your website
i think it's i think i don't understand
how this lady
could try and buy like how do you vote
for joe biden and then try and buy ammo
online that's the crazy thing to me like
when you said
you realize that if joe biden's policies
enacted my business
is gone and you can't buy ammo anyway
right
did she not understand that yeah she
said well um
if you can't sell ammo on the internet
then you can just you'll have to just
sell it to the gun stores
and the big distributors and that's
where people will end up buying it
uh it was it was a really odd
conversation
to be honest with you i it was difficult
because
we we couldn't really see him it was
very hard to get
to her her core principles right because
she told me she bought a gun that
because she wanted to be able to defend
her family and i said well that's great
i i applaud that i think that's a great
idea
i said what kind of gun did you buy she
said i have a glock 19. and i said well
hey great so do i uh did you know that
joe biden wants to ban magazines with a
capacity of more than 10 rounds and a
glock 19 comes with a 15 round magazine
from the factory what do you think about
that
and she said well i wouldn't have a
problem with that i would i would turn
in my 15 round magazines and i don't
think i need more than i don't think i
need more than 10 rounds to defend my
family
and i said well i
would disagree with you on that premise
and we can we can discuss the specifics
of that did you ask her if she's ever
gone to a range
yeah i said did have you done any formal
firearms training and she
she claimed that she did and she
wouldn't tell me who's lying
probably uh but i said you know did you
know that and this is
this is a a real statistic uh thank you
trek at
mdfi for the information but uh expert
law enforcement officers in uh shooting
encounters
what what percentage of the rounds they
fire do you think
actually hit the target seven
if we go and look at the seven seven
percent ten percent
seven percent is it seven percent what
do you think
uh i think it's at like seven percent
yeah i think it's super low it's it's 18
so it's still low but so you know for
every 10 rounds fired 1.8 of those
and and that that counts if i aimed at
your chest and i hit you in the big toe
that counts as a hit
right so the point is there's just no
there's no data there's no science
there's no research that says
uh you only need 10 rounds that that's
somehow an arbit
that's a number that somebody pulled out
of their head and
she just couldn't seem to i couldn't
seem to get it into her that
that is a limitation that she's going to
have to figure out and she
she said well you know but joe biden's
not taking away my right to own a gun
i can still own the gun i just can't
have more than 10 rounds and i said okay
well what happens if he
says you can only have two rounds right
what about a single shotgun
well that's fine because i'll still be
able to carry a gun so he's not
infringing up on my rights
like okay well you know yeah you can
carry the gun but no bullets
i can spend two hours on the phone with
you if if you want and we can go back
and forth but
it's just clear that we're never gonna
you you don't get it
and i can't i can't seem to to get it
into you any further than it is
do we need an amendment that says you
have the right to bear ammo
well um you know the problem with the
second amendment
is it's very it's very general and
i think the founders intended that
because they wanted it to cover
more than ju people think that the
founders were
were simple creatures and
i think that's just incredibly false
so if you look at the wording of the
second amendment it is very
general and sort of non-specific but
i think that was the intent they knew
that times would change
weapons would would change technology
would advance i mean it's my belief the
second amendment is really more about
human the ability for humans to use
technology to defend themselves more
than it is about
uh firearms specifically what are your
feelings and i don't accelerate the
conversation too much we talk about this
from time to time but what are your
feelings about people owning like
larger caliber weapons and like heavy
weapons and high explosive weapons and
things like that
well uh i don't have a problem with it
at all i think we have far too many gun
laws on the books already
that's one of my biggest complaints with
people
on the conservative and the right end of
the political spectrum
they seem to not be interested in
rolling back things that are already in
place
they claim that they want to prevent any
more infringements but
they never really discuss getting
anything back so
heavy weapons specifically you know back
in the 1700s and 1800s
people owned warships and and cannons
and it wasn't a problem
then i don't know oh i'm sorry it was it
was less than a problem
governments consigned them asked them
for help sure corsairs and privateers
you'd have the crown of great britain
being like we need more private mass
you know uh destroyers and frigates can
we find any private citizens that have
mass massive warships that that could
help us out and they loved it you know
why
they would write uh i forgot what it was
called letters of mark letters of mark
that's exactly it
and what would happen is these private
sales
corsairs and privateers would go and
basically get car
cart blanche to attack the spaniards the
french the dutch
and then if they got caught the british
the crown the brits could be like oh
they're pirates oh heavens we we're mad
at them same as you
right the original the original uh eric
prince and blackwater right
exactly that was the point ian made
earlier yeah
i think it's called blackwater these old
colonial warship owners are now
corporate they've formed corporations
that have made like black water and
other arms but they were they
i mean it was still not too dissimilar
back then right right like
like back then there were no was that
before corporations well they're not
really before no
it was east india trading company yeah
these kind of modern
i think i think the first major modern
corporation was like the brooklyn bridge
corporation i think
it was intended to form and then
dissolve but then it had to be
maintained or something i was reading
about
gross but but i i i don't want to
deviate the conversation too much
yeah so uh anyway we're talking about so
so about heavy weapons i mean
you know back in the the days of the
founders they they had the same weapons
as
as the military and the founders
understood that that was necessary
it's impossible to s to mount
a rebellion against a tyrannical
government
if the balance of power gets shifted too
far so if we look at today
you know you you have people on the gun
control
side arguing that they want to ban ar-15
rifles basic
semi-automatic rifles that have been in
existence since the mid-60s
but our government and our military have
drones and
hellfire missiles and mraps and
shoulder-fired rockets so
you know we we need to the balance of
power is already so
grossly out of whack i i don't i don't
necessarily agree though
i understand what you're saying that
they're the you know the government's
weapons are
monstrous monstrously disproportionate
to the average person
but this is something that we see the
left bring up quite a bit you'll never
stop the u.s government from being
tyrannical because they have you know
drones and cruise missiles and things
like that and then i just say
vietnam afghanistan well i agree 100 i
think
um you know accuracy by volume i guess
you would say you know we have
you can't occupy city streets with
drones correct i agree i i
think um what i'll i guess i'll i'll uh
clarify what i mean is it shouldn't
we we should it the the balance of power
should be much tighter
so if the government has drones and m
raps and missiles i mean
why can't we have a machine gun well we
can't have a machine gun because
of prohibition that's that's basically
where that all started i'm going to end
up being the guy that's like well what
about this weapon what about this weapon
what about drones drone bombers do you
think that private citizens should have
access to drone
explosives what what do you mean like
have a radio controlled
drone bomber that you could fly over
someone's house and drop a bomb on it
and you have that
me i mean any private citizen could just
easily do that like a hellfire missile
not a hellfire missile
but you can buy a drone from best buy
and do crazy things with it like level
of building
yeah i mean depending on the building
not legally i
i actually consulted on this i i was
doing a consultation for
universities university was a coalition
with the government
and they were talking about potential
problems with drones and i said what are
you going to do
when i'm not going to name the companies
because they'll probably get mad at me
for saying their name
but we know these these consumer great
drones what do you do when you're in new
york and you see one of them
zip over your head down fifth avenue
armed with explosives
you can't stop it it's there it's in the
city it's armed the bomb is on it
there's nothing you can do oh sure you
can knock it out of the sky
detonate it where it is but you can't
commandeer it and send it somewhere else
encrypted controls it's already here but
but we're not legally allowed to own
them
at the moment sure sure i don't know
what a
private citizen would would need that
for necessarily but i suppose if the
second amendment
is referencing explosive devices then i
guess there's like at what point does a
weapon become
offensive as opposed to defensive well i
guess my it's all offensive
yeah everything i was offensive my
answer to that would be murder is
illegal and so if i as the
operator of that weapon system decide
that i can live with the ramifications i
i had this argument with
i think it was the assistant lieutenant
governor
of michigan i was at an anti-gun rally
trying to be a troll more or less and i
i said to him he was talking about
banning ar-15s and i said
you know i have one of those in my in my
bedroom that's what i would use to
defend
my home why do you think that that's
not something i should be able to do and
i said
let's take that a step further if if
there's a
you know a murderer in my kitchen and i
happen to have a grenade and i decide
that i want to throw this grenade at him
and i'm willing to live with the fact
that i'm going to have to
remodel my entire kitchen and
i know that it's not going to damage my
neighbor's house
does it really make a difference if if
he dies by grenade or if he guy
dies by an ar-15 or if he dies
because i take out a kitchen knife and i
stab him to death in my kitchen
because he's there to kill me or my
family like what difference does it make
to you can you can you tell me what
moral or you know ethical principle
make you think makes the difference
between those scenarios
and he didn't really have an answer oh
that's ridiculous that would never
happen
and yeah probably but it
it doesn't get at the core of the
question which is how
how can a politician decide how best
for me to defend my life in in
in a situation where it it's necessary
for me to do so you know if i
if i kill somebody with a gun and i
shouldn't have killed that person i'm
going to jail
if i kill somebody with a hellfire
missile and
that person didn't deserve to die then
i'm going to jail no probably not
probably not i mean when the u.s like uh
uh that's true obama
obama didn't go to jail that's right
totally legal yeah right no problem
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you